scrolling is the new smoking be careful
how you use your smartphone we've got a
reminder for you you can download the
free scrolling is the new smoking
wallpaper over at the minimalists comm
slash wallpapers almost every holiday
and family event is held at our house
the time spent with loved ones is
irreplaceable but the amount of
decorations knickknacks and holiday
themed items can be a burden how can we
how can we help make these special days
flow better with less after clutter
which that could be a good episode title
by the way after clutter or melt wash
more that's a pretty good one to show ya
after clutter like that is like okay
would you you cook a big dinner for
people you have after dishes right but
yeah you have some sort of holiday event
and you've you've made these especially
the big holidays like Christmas that we
feel require a lot of decorations don't
actually require a lot of decoration we
feel that they do yeah afterward you're
like it's almost like a parody at the
end of a party in a movie you're like
all this clutter everywhere
how can someone like Alexander better
enjoy these times but have less after
clutter so I just want to say I recently
wrote an article about this very topic
how everybody loves photographing brunch
oh I made this beautiful brunch party
for my friend but then they never talk
about what goes into cleaning up after
that brush how was my whole article Ryan
was doing something a while ago I think
that's while we were on tour I don't
remember exactly when it was but because
people would like they think the most
perfect beautiful brunch cellphones have
ruined nice restaurants it's like it's
like it's turned into a photo shoot did
you hear about the restaurant which
restaurant it was was doing was AOC
maybe oh maybe were they banned well
what they did actually no I forget what
what it may have not been whoever was
like they would see people and they
don't they don't ban the phone I'll say
stop taking pictures of the food they
say oh we're really glad you enjoyed the
presentation of the food I'll tell you
what what we do our chef's each day take
photos of each of the dishes that we
prepare and we post it to our Instagram
account so you can repost professional
photos exactly what you ate today which
the menu changes every day and that way
you don't have to worry about trying to
take it in this lighting which is an
ideal for your right yeah I mean heaven
forbid you just eat the food and enjoy
it without letting everyone know how
much you enjoyed it well social media so
something Ryan did is sort of like a
parody of this is he was taking you take
a photo of the plate after the food was
easy plate what you should have seen
this dish it was delicious
to answer this question I I've seen this
with so many people but to me the
biggest challenges this year it's like
what's my house gonna look like for
holiday 2019 it should look the same as
holiday 2018 it shouldn't look the same
as holiday 1987 like we can certainly
move up a little bit but I think when it
comes to decor and holiday you know
accoutrement I think it's very important
to be mindful about what it is that
you're bringing into your home do you
need nine pumpkins for Halloween around
your house and in your living room or do
you need one on your porch and then
everybody knows it's Halloween and we
can sort of move on so in my house we so
I'm Jewish my husband is not he's others
so we celebrate Christmas and Jewish
holidays Hanukkah as well so we have
very minimal decorations we have a
menorah for the days of Hanukkah and
then we have our Christmas tree which we
decorate as well and it's beautiful and
we have a nice storage bag for all of
our ornaments and what I I don't know
the technical terminology because I
didn't grow up with all of them but we
have our storage bags for that and it's
not like we go to the store of year and
buy 12 new ornaments it's like we have
it we have we decorate we put it away it
is a lot of time
mm-hm and I think if you are planning to
decorate you have to schedule in that
time you have to know it's going to be
there on the back end and let that be a
lesson to you that when you're setting
your house up and you're getting ready
for your family and friends to come over
how much do you want to lay out
because you're gonna have to put it away
right just think about that think about
I remember late driving around we were
kids to see you there are always the
houses that really went overboard with
the Christmas decorations and the nice
thing about that is you can go
appreciate them without having to own
all those lights yourself there's
someone who's passionate about putting
up seven thousand dollars worth of
Christmas decorations and you don't have
to spend a penny on it you can walk past
it you can look at it you can enjoy it
we'll go to we'll take Ella down to it
we did this what last year Rodeo Drive
yeah at Christmas and it's weird to have
celebrate Christmas in Christmas and
Ocean Villas it is awesome but growing
up in the Midwest which you're from the
Midwest as well
it's just Canada but it's it is still
the middle median Midwestern of the
Western world and so you're used to snow
and cold and and the that correlates
with the Christmas music you hear at the
retail stores and all this other stuff
right but then you're here and you're
like it's cooler than it is in summer
but it's still 67 degrees but the
Christmas lights are on palm trees here
and so it's a different experience which
makes it a different kind of awesome
because it is a new experience for me
yeah I really love it well you know the
thing that Alexander says in his
question too is the you know the time
spent with the loved ones is
irreplaceable and that's really what
it's about right it's not about I mean
the did the decorations really add that
much to that time spent with loved ones
if they do great like I know I had a
girlfriend whose mom had like 300
Santa's or something crazy that she put
all over the house from big to small
Santa's to like the little Russian doll
Santa's I mean it was like serious an
effete a serious serious Santa fetish
and and now I have inappropriate jokes I
want to say no so so those things really
like she loved him they like I could
tell like she just like walked into room
she got this nice one
fuzzy feeling and she never complained
about putting out those Santa's like she
enjoyed putting those out a she'd never
complain when she had to take them down
never complain about the decorations so
if that's where you're at
Alexander great like then to decorate
your house but if it's causing you a
bunch of stress and a bunch of pain like
you've got to be able to look in the
mirror and be like this is a net
negative I cannot continue to do this
cuz nothing is worth doing if it's if
it's going to bring you more stress than
joy there are some traditions you can
carry forward that are still enhancing
the experience that are that are
enhancing this excuse me the
irreplaceable time spent with loved ones
and that's great I think of your growing
up or you would like leave cookies and
milk out for Santa Claus like who's
gonna come over my mom was an alcoholic
so she left cookies and beer out genius
yeah Santa comes in and you're gonna
need a beer I thought you're gonna say
beer and cigarettes she liked cookies
too but there are there are traditions
that you can carry forward but sometimes
there are some traditions that are no
longer useful for you and your family
maybe you grew up with them and you
don't get any value from them and it's
okay to leave those behind
you